- Our next guest is a
Grammy award-winning,
legendary music icon whose contributions
to art and music and culture span decades.
Thanks to her, we've been on our feet
and catching the rhythm
and doing the conga
for the last 40 years.
Please welcome the
glorious Gloria Estefan.
(audience claps)
- Oh.
My gosh.
- Oh my-
- What a warming
introduction.
And I'm a huge fan of yours,
Drew, by the way, hello.
- I love you so much.
- We all are.
- And by the way, you look so beautiful.
- Oh, thank you so much.
And what a privilege to be on your show.
- There's so much to celebrate.
We're having a hard time figuring out,
like, which subject to prioritize
of your incredibly multi-diverse life.
One of the things was that you had said,
I believe, that your 40s were
one of your favorite decades?
- Yes, absolutely.
You know, when people say,
"Oh no, I'm turning 40,"
especially women, okay, I tell them,
"That's my favorite decade."
It was...
You know, you're still hot.
My body was on point
'cause I'd been working out
so much after that accident
too, and I got a little miracle
when I was 37, that they had told me
I'd never be able to have another baby
and I had my daughter, Emily.
So it was the best years of my life.
I actually took time off from touring
to be able to go to her games
'cause she was an amazing
basketball player,
starting in 5th grade,
and she was a musician
and I would go to all her
shows and take her to school.
We took her to school
every day, Emilio and I,
and I picked her up.
So I really, I had the luxury at that time
to be able to really
choose what I wanted to do.
But yeah, 40s were magnificent,
and every, every decade's been great
'cause I always say you're
either older or dead.
- Yeah.
- So I'll take
whatever comes with it.
- The reason I love hearing
you talk about your 40s
with, you know, a beautiful
reverie and positivity
is I'm smack dab in the
middle of them right now.
and this decade,
- Yes.
Without question, has
been the best of my life.
And I'm glad that we were
able to have these life paths
where we can focus on work
and then take time off
when we had our kids, and
that's such a blessing
and it is a luxury.
- It is a luxury.
It's a luxury, and not many women
can take their kids to work, which I did
because I was on tour all over the world.
And when Emily was two, we went on tour
with my then 16-year-old
son and her at two.
And they'd see their mom
bigger than life on that stage
and then want to spend time after.
Then I became Mommy after the show.
And it's a great grounding
and beautiful experience
and I wouldn't have had it any other way.
(audience claps)
- Oh my gosh.
Talking to you is such an inspiration.
And your husband, Emilio,
you guys married in 1978?
- Yes, indeed.
We've been married 42 years.
45 together. The first
one, he was my boss.
Yeah, it's been great.
I am a blessed woman.
He is a feminist.
He's the most incredibly supportive man,
and to everyone, he's a motivator.
He gets up every day raring to go
and he finds new things to do
and still recording this amazing album
for The Wailers this year
and he's working on music constantly,
makes my life as easy
as he can every moment,
and he's just a lovable
guy, and very funny.
He makes me laugh every day of my life.
He's really an amazing guy.
- I think, if there's a way to, like,
subconsciously submerge ourselves
in all men's minds right now,
I do believe a secret way
into a woman's heart is humor, 100%.
- Yes.
- And a daily kindness, I think,
just goes the longest way.
And I know that you're
doing the Red Table Talks
with your niece, Lili,
- Yes.
- and your daughter, Emily.
And when we come back, I
want to talk about this
because I am so excited for this
for all of us that I just
can't wait to dive in.
And when you are able to
share the life journey
with other people so that
other people don't feel alone
and we can benefit from
each other's wisdom
and there's a diversity within
your family of experiences.
(upbeat music)